[Musique]
la formation la plus importante de la
journée me semble être le retour du
printemps et je trouve qu'il est un peu
cruelle de votre part michel crépeau de
nous faire quitter la campagne en fleurs
pour la campagne électorale nous pensons
tous que vous avez de bonnes raisons
pour retenir notre attention pendant 18
minutes et vous connaissant ayant appris
vous connaître depuis maintenant
quelques mois je suis persuadé que vous
allez donner à cette campagne une allure
un peu moins austère et un peu plus
souriante
vous allez nous éviter de faire l'école
buissonnière puisque vous nous envoyer
directement tous ceux qui vous écoute
qui vous voit aujourd'hui et moi
directement à l'école car c'est la
première proposition du manifeste
radical
la première des douze propositions que
vous faites français sous le titre
l'avenir en face
alors pourquoi cette priorité à l'école
oui c'est une espèce de défi dans le
fond ne parlait de l'école comme presque
tout le monde part en vacances j'attache
beaucoup d'importance à l'école et je
crois vraiment que je ne serai pas un
radical si je ne croyais pas que les
vrais progrès les seuls progrès qui
comptent sont les progrès de l'homme je
ne crois pas tellement la transformation
des structures
je suis tout à fait convaincu c'est tout
le sens de ma démarche que le changement
politique il viendra d'une nouvelle
répartition du savoir et d'une nouvelle
répartition du pouvoir mais que
reprochez vous à l'école d'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de choses georges de caunes
beaucoup de choses car je crois que
personne n'est satisfait de l'école les
enseignants sont mécontents
les parents sont inquiets et les jeunes
dans le fond ne se sentent pas tellement
concerné par l'enseignement qu'on leur
propose
ils savent très bien que l'école
d'aujourd'hui c'est la grande machine
fabriquée les insatisfaits les chômeurs
et des jeunes qui très souvent très
souvent se rend handicapés pour la vie
et cela n'est pas acceptable
je ne l'acceptent pas je crois que si la
gauche arrive au pouvoir ce que je
souhaite
il est indispensable et urgent qu'elle
fasse un effort considérable
pour remettre l'école d'enseignement
candy l'école évidemment c'est
l'enseignement à l'heure de notre temps
quelles sont vos propositions michel
côté je crois qu'il y en aurait beaucoup
mais il ya au moins trois grandes
directions dans lesquelles il me paraît
indispensable de s'orienter d'abord
aujourd'hui l'éducation ne peut être que
permanente
l'idée qu'on va aller à l'école à
prendre jusqu'à 16 ans ou même à 18 ou
même à 25
et puis qu'après bas on travaillera dans
sa profession
on leur à la télévision on fera je ne
sais pas encore mais par une idée
complètement dépassé nous sommes dans un
monde qui change très vite
tout au long de la vie il faut
maintenant apprendre autre chose
être capable aussi de s'adapter être
capable d'innover et l'école doit
toujours être à l'image de la société
une société est à l'image de son école
et c'est au tour de l'école qu'il faut
reconstruire la démocratie
le patronat a l'a compris depuis
longtemps les recyclage pour les pdg ça
existe depuis très longtemps mais ça
n'existe pas pour la masse des
françaises et des français ils vont à
l'école jusqu'à 16 ou 18 ans quelquefois
un peu plus tard quand ils vont à
l'université
et puis après c'est fini ils sont
abandonnés à eux mêmes et ce problème de
l'éducation permanente mettre au fond
inséparables inséparable des problèmes
de la réduction du temps de travail
qu'un dé grande question qui va se poser
aux hommes de notre génération c'est
celle de savoir comment on va organiser
le temps de la vie entre la partie où
l'on doit apprendre la partie où on doit
entreprendre et la partie où on doit
enseigner jouer tout le monde tour à
tour soit enseignant enseigner ça me
paraît une bonne règle de vie ne
trouvez-vous pas michel crépeau que
l'école est aussi un peu trop parisienne
et que nos ancêtres ont un peu trop
gaulois et coûter trop parisienne
peut-être pas parce que paris ça compte
beaucoup dans la france mais je crois
que l'enseignement est beaucoup trop
centralisée qu'il faut le décentraliser
enfin l éducation nationale c'est
aujourd'hui en france une des plus
grandes entreprises du monde
huit cent mille fonctionnaires ça
correspond à peu près à ce qu'est
l'armée soviétique
c'est beaucoup plus que general motors
et cela n'est pas satisfaisant que tous
à peu près ce décide de paris c'est
pourquoi je propose que l'on sait par
l'enseignement de cet enseignement
permanent j'entends bien un enseignement
de base pour tout le monde est
indispensable et qui doit être dans les
règles
les normes et les programmes doivent
être fixées dans une grande charte de
l'éducation dangereux surtout pas que ce
soit une réforme de plus parce que tous
les ministres qui sont succédé sous la
vème république ont tous eu leur réforme
c'est un prétexte à ne rien faire une
grande charte de l'éducation pluriannuel
avec les moyens les moyens que cela
suppose
enfin il faut dire que dans un pays
comme le japon l'effort pour l'éducation
point de vue financier est à peu près du
double de celui qui est fait en france
bon et ensuite une autre part de
l'enseignement correspondant précisément
à la peur permanente de l'enseignement
qui elle soit décentralisée régionalisée
et en fin de compte cogéré par les
enseignants par les parents par les
enfants on doit quand même consulté sur
ce qui les intéresse d'apprendre les
élus locaux aussi ont leur mot à dire
je crois que tout le monde a son mot à
dire dans l'école que ça ne peut pas
être une affaire corporatisme ne peut
pas être une affaire qui décident depuis
paris cette décentralisation de la part
de l'enseignement qui concerne toute
intelligence tout ce qui concerne
l'homme en fin de compte me par est
indispensable puis je vous rappeler
michel crépeau qu'à l'époque de jules
ferry en donner à l'école une
instruction civique
oui entre autres mais l'école de jules
ferry mois que j'aime beaucoup comme
radical j'y suis très attaché ou
comprenait le chichon a créé le tableau
noir la plume sergent major l'encré
violette les instituteurs de la 3e
batterie m'a fait sourire avec son temps
moi je pense plutôt à la vie alors ce
que je veux dire c'est que le jules
ferry l'école de jules ferry était
adaptée aux besoins des hommes de ce
temps l'école d'aujourd'hui n'est plus
adapté aux besoins des hommes de notre
temps en particulier ce qui manque c'est
toute la dimension des sciences humaines
alors vous avez raison l'éducation
civique
on demande aux gens de participer
davantage à la vie publique même d'élire
le président de la république
1 et bien en fait plus d'instruction
civique pratiquement plus dans un pays
chargé d'histoire comme l'est la france
on n'enseigne plus l'histoire
et puis il ya tout l'aspect aussi de la
philosophie de la morale de
l'apprentissage de la sagesse moi je
crois que notre monde c'est pas de
pétrole qui manque c'est un an tout de
sagesse et puis il ya tout l'aspect
aussi de l'enseignement artistique qui
me paraît déterminant vous savez dans
une société dans notre monde on se
préoccupe de ce qui est utile de ce qui
est utile et l'économie il ya tout ce
qui est utile à l'homme il faut se
préoccuper davantage de ce qui est beau
de ce qui est bien de ce qui rend
heureux et puis je voudrais parler aussi
du sport il ne faut pas qu'ils ne vont
pas oublier parce que ça fait partie de
l'éducation ça fait partie de danse et
non je crois qu une vie bien équilibrée
si vous voulez eh bien elle comporte une
part à l'esprit une part aux qualités du
caire et puis il part aussi à la culture
physique c'est tout à fait essentielle
ne serait ce que pour meubler ce temps
libre ce temps des loisirs qui va
devenir beaucoup plus important des
têtes bien faites autant que de fait
bien play où il c'est ça l'humanisme
c'est vrai c'est tout à fait valable
pour notre temps car maman de la
renaissance devient un formidable
bouleversement des données du monde et
des techniques la culture aujourd'hui
michel cacouault quelle est votre
définition de la culture un chacun doit
donner sa définition de la culture
moi je crois qu'on peut pas séparer la
culture la culture de la vie vous savez
quand on a choisi le sigle du mrj on a
mis un arbre dans l'hexagone les gens
ont cru que c'était par souci d'écologie
j'accorde certes une très grande
importance au problème de
l'environnement je crois que de leçons à
recevoir de personne et que personne n'a
le monopole de l'écologie mais si j'ai
mis là c'est pas comme symbole
d'écologie c'est comme symbole de
culture parce qu'un arbre ça comporte
quoi ça comporte des racines je crois
que chacun doit retrouver ses racines au
niveau régional en particulier dans les
cultures régionales les landes
régionales l'histoire régionale les arts
à régionaux et puis un tronc et tout un
tronc commun puis surtout il ya le
feuillage qui se renouvelle chaque année
qui représente une dimension essentielle
pour moi de la culture parce que c'est
la création
je crois que l'homme il est riche non
pas de ce qu'ils donnent les qui les
riches n'ont pas de ce qu'il reçoit mais
de ce qu'il donne et de ce qu'il sait et
tout le sens de la culture que l'on
devrait placer au coeur de la cité la
maison de la culture
on devrait être au coeur de la cité
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire la
rochelle et c'est ce que j'ai fait à la
rochelle temps précisément à prendre à
tout le monde que chaque individu choc
comme chaque fin à toute époque de la
vie a une capacité de création qui doit
exercer cette capacité de traction non
seulement dans le domaine économique
mais dans tous les domaines car tout se
tient et c'est pourquoi je voudrais que
l'état fasse sans saveur de la culture
l'effort qui s'impose enfin dans un pays
comme la france dont la culture est une
dimension essentielle parce que si la
france passe pour un grand pays dans le
monde vous savez c'est pas parce qu'on
vend des avions des chars c'est parce
qu'il ya la culture française en même
temps que les droits de l'homme
d'ailleurs dont nous reparlerons
et bien quand on vote la france fait un
effort de 0 50 % de son budget pour la
culture qu'une grande partie de ce
budget est utilisé pour des activités de
prestige les actions de prestige
beaucoup plus que pour une culture
populaire une culture en profondeur qui
permette vraiment la création quand on
voit en effet que là aussi tout est
centralisé à paris je prendrai l'exemple
des musées il ya des trésors qui dorment
dans les caves des murs des musées
nationaux et qu'il conviendrait
d'envoyer en province qu il ya une
rotation que le musée lui aussi comme
l'école soit ouvert sur la vie que le
livre se trouve au coeur même de la cité
que la télévision l'audiovisuel qui est
un formidable moyen
sur le plan culturel soit utilisée comme
il le faudrait et sans parler des
grandes transformations de la technique
aussi qu interviennent avec la vidéo
nous allons aborder une époque toute
assez le passionnante moi j'ai pas du
tout peur de l'avenir je crois que notre
génération a vu une fantastique aventure
mais que ce que cet avenir
et bien il ne faut pas le subir il faut
d'abord essayer de l'appréhender est ce
qui est très important et fait partie de
l'action culturelle car c'est à partir
du passé aussi qu'on peut reconstruire
le présent c'est tout progrès c'est une
tradition qui se prolonge
je suis en train de prolonger mois la
tradition radicale sur le plan politique
maintenant un langage tout à fait
différent de celui que tenait les
notables d'autrefois mais je crois que
c'est à partir de cette action
culturelle qu'on peut envisager de
maîtriser cet avenir de le contrôler je
crois que la volonté des hommes doit
l'emporter sur la fatalité des choses
c'est tout le sens de notre démarche
politique à partir de l'éducation de la
culture peut-être de l'information puis
chacun peut nous allons en parler
j'enregistre simplement j'interprète ce
que vous avez dit mais que la grande
compétition dans le monde c'est une
compétition culturelle avant tout bien
sûr parce qu'il a une dimension
internationale de la culture qui paraît
très importante aussi valérie adipi bien
longtemps le temps du monde fini
commence c'est vrai plus que jamais
voyez la malle est de l'américaine
ripoll oui je parle de paul valéry jeune
ronan l'autre nous sauver l'autre la
culture cet autre chose je viens vous
l'avez abordé justement le chapitre de
la presse la presse écrite la radio la
télévision je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire sur les médias en effet
beaucoup je ne vous permets pas toutes
les raisons que nous aurions de nous
plaindre je veux surtout parler de ce
qu'il faut faire
la presse l'information ça c'est parti
la culture dans facebook permet de
connaître ce qui se passe autour de nous
la culture et ouverture sur le monde par
conséquent sur l'actualité donc le rôle
de la presse d'une presse qui souhaitent
diversifier d'une presti swell libre me
paraît au coeur même du problème
culturel par conséquent je souhaiterais
que dans ce domaine salissant la presse
nationale où on assiste à des
concentrations franche allez vous
demander où il ya des journaux qui
disparaît sa disparition de libération
par exemple me paraît quelque chose de
tout à fait regrettable certes il ya des
journaux libres comme le canard enchaîné
et bien d'autres et puis on
nationale on peut quand même à peu près
choisir mais ça serait ce pas voyez que
monsieur ressemble par exemple à
l'aurore le figaro françois c'est
toujours monsieur versant qui finalement
contrôler tout ça au niveau régional
aussi je crois que la presse régionale
est une dimension essentielle de la vie
régionale et de la culture régionale qui
vous faire en sorte que cette presse
régionale puis se vivre et survivre dans
une certaine indépendance indépendance
certaines ou plus exactement la
télévision est heureuse de vous
accueillir à cette occasion michel
qu'elle pourra vendre par la télévision
n'aurait pas ça parlait des radios
libres aussi la libye parce que le moyen
est formé de transmettre de communiquer
de communiquer la communication je crois
que c'est le plus grand de tous les de
tous les trésors et bien la
communication et elle doit aussi
s'adapter aux données techniques du
temps le progrès de la démocratie
c'était le droit de réunion
le droit de faire des meetings le droit
de publier des journaux aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on peut refuser à personne le
droit de démettre sur les ondes mais la
liberté n'est jamais la pagaille si vous
voulez et là aussi il faut faire en
sorte que si nous faisons des radios
libres et c'est le sens de la
proposition de loi que j'ai déposée sur
les radios libres et bien que ce ne soit
pas là aussi quelque chose qui ce que
s'approprie l'argent ou que s'approprie
le pouvoir ce soit le pouvoir d'état où
le pouvoir local et de ce point de vue
peut-être aussi dangereux que moi tiens
pas du tout je crois pas que ce soit un
progrès d'avoir radio crépeau à la
rochelle ou radio georges marchais dans
le val de marne
pas du tout il faut des cahiers des
charges il faut surtout organiser le
financement de ces radios lit parce que
si c'est la grande surface du coin qui
doit financer la radio libre croyez moi
que sur le plan culturel ce ne sera pas
très brillant michel crépeau pardon
quand même un peu de la télévision sur
mon peut-on dire beaucoup de choses mon
cher georges alors alors attaqué
michalet bientôt attaquer je crois que
la télévision c'est le moyen moderne
d'informations encore excellence même le
moyen des campagnes électorales et ceux
qui sont au pouvoir et les cadrans le
savent parfaitement
on peut dire qu'ils se sont partagés la
télévision durant la précampagne
électorale pendant des mois et des mois
on les a vu apparaître alors qu'elle
voulait être y voir demain
vous allez faire exactement la même
annonce justement si on devait si on
devait prendre le pouvoir si la gauche
devait prendre le pouvoir pour faire la
même chose avec l'information est ce
danger existe et ce danger existe ce
serait pas la peine quelques changements
je crois qu'il faut j'ai fait des
propositions concrètes dans mon
manifeste là dessus je crois qu'il faut
recréer au niveau de l'audiovisuel c'est
à la télévision au moins le pluralisme
qui existe encore dans la presse écrite
et ne font plus que l'état soit
majoritaire dans les conseils
d'administration et puisque nous avons
plusieurs chaînes et bien que les
électeurs que les les téléspectateurs
quand ils paient la redevance puisse
dire à qui ils donnent leur argent à
quelle chaîne in de leur argent et vote
il faudrait faire d'enseignants l'inde
ont d'ailleurs de votre système c'est
que vous avez faire des chaînes
partisane moi je plaide l'objet de notre
ère georges deschênes partisane
actuellement toutes sont partisanes et
toutes sont du même parti alors je
préfère plusieurs chaînes partisane ce
qui laisse la possibilité de comparer
comme quand j'achète l'humanité mon chat
qui je donne mon argent chez ce que je
vais lire dans la chaîne le vieillard au
jeu chez eux je sais à qui je donne mon
argent je sais ce que je vais gage peut
comparer les deux je voudrais qu'à la
télévision on puisse en faire autant ce
serait déjà un fantastique progrès un
fantastique progrès une garantie en tout
cas pour la liberté des citoyens est le
libre choix de l'électeur pascal
tellement nous dit bernanke les sondages
et les petits candidats les grands
candidats mais moi par exemple juste 0
60% du temps de parole en 1981 à la télé
you l'aï d'abord puis toujours sonder
les gens leur parler de tripoli
connaissent pas très peu y voit jamais
j'espère que vous aurez davantage
d'occasions après les élections
actuelles chaque poteau mais entre nous
je voudrais vous poser une question pour
terminer objectivement est-ce que vous
pensez que vous avez les moyens de
changer quelque chose bien si vraiment
je croyais que ma campagne étaient
utiles je ne serai pas candidat deux
sens à cette campagne d'abord dire un
certain nombre de choses que les autres
ne lis pas me paraît tout à fait
indispensable et puis surtout sa vie un
homme politique yves hausse qui pèse et
ça dépend du nombre de voix que j'aurais
au premier tour si j'ai suffisamment de
voix
je pourrais et je n'y manquerai pas
croyez-moi peser sur les orientations du
gouvernement
de la gauche dans le sens des idées de
la liberté de l'exercice collectif et
individuel de la responsabilité ce que
représente le radicalisme
qu'est ce que nous sommes en fin de
compte nous représentons et là je me
sens très bien dans ma peau maire de la
rochelle finalement c'est l'esprit de
réforme
l'esprit de libre examen l'esprit de
tolérance c'est le radicalisme qui a
donné la république à la france faudrait
pas l'oublier
je crois que c'est le radicalisme qui
peut la lui rendre les français sont
fondamentalement à dix communes oubliées
souvent par la faute des radicaux eux
mêmes et n'ont pas su moderniser leur
langage l'actualiser qui sont divisés
aujourd'hui je veux rassembler les
radicaux je veux rassembler toutes
celles et tous ceux qui en france
souhaite non pas la révolution mais
souhaite de profondes réformes qui
s'imposent dans tous les domaines et je
crois que la grande réforme
ce sera précisément cette nouvelle
répartition du savoir dont nous venons
de parler
le vote utile le 26 avril ce sera le
vote différents nous avons une élection
à deux tours
il faut savoir en profiter faut pas se
tromper d'élection au premier tour il
faut choisir ses préférences et il faut
que les françaises et les français
montrent qu'ils veulent du changement
dans la politique que les quatre drones
ont fait leur tente il faut autre chose
et au second tour tout naturellement
c'est la règle du jeu on se rassemblera
pour gagner pour le changement c'est ma
candidature qui serait utile pour le
changement
j'en suis sûr
[Musique]